welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer for house of the dragon adapted
from george rr martin's game of thrones
prequel fire and blood recounting the
history of the targaryen civil war known
as the dance of the dragons aka how
unnecessary but fascinating drama is
provoked by [ __ ] succession customs
kid fights and incest the series
premieres on august 21st on hbo max and
since i started on this channel by
analyzing game of thrones i cannot wait
to return to westeros and remember when
i was a younger youtube breaker downer
invisibly terrified to be in front of a
camera worried that speaking too loud
would piss off the neighbors now i don't
care oh and as i break this down i
understand a lot of people may be
watching the show without having read
fire and blood which is totally okay but
i will be talking about some of the
events that happened in the book but not
the really cool big spoilery stuff that
happens later in the book because i
think those will happen in later seasons
of this show so don't worry i have your
back i'm not going to ruin it for you
but if you want to go in completely
blind you know maybe don't click on
youtube videos about this let's dive in
here we go
the dream
it was clearer than a memory
okay we open on princess rhaenyra
targaryen in the red keep seeing someone
on the iron throne so this story is all
about the succession from her father
king viserys the first he was the fifth
king of the targaryen dynasty that was
started by aegon the conqueror so it
went aegon the first then amy's the
first then maegor the first then
jaehaerys the first and now viserys the
first viserys is actually the grandson
to jiharis viserys is pointed by a
council of lords so really king after
king it's just been kind of a mess
viserys is one of the namesakes of
daenerys brother viserys that we saw in
game of thrones but this viserys is 10
generations before we meet them rhaenyra
is viserys's firstborn but since she's a
female others want viserys's younger
brother damon to be the heir rhaenyra's
mother emma died giving birth to the son
balon who also died a day later viserys
then remarried to allison hightower and
produced two sons with her aegon ii and
his younger brother eamond and then
later on alison and her faction want the
line of succession to continue through
aegon so two factions form some
supporting the princess rhaenyra the
blacks others supporting the queen
alicent and her father otto and her sons
they go by the greens green versus black
here in this opening shot you see the
iron throne is now actually closer in
its appearance to george r martin's book
descriptions it wasn't just a normal
sized throne or a chair made out of
swords it was supposed to be a giant
mound a thick nest of swords closer to a
briar patch with steps leading up
through this tangle of swords but since
they want to keep some continuity with
the hbo series you can see how they kept
that throne but then had this briar
patchy tangle of swords surrounding it
so you can still see how this throne
later leads to the throne we see in the
later era director miguel sapochnick who
directed some of the best episodes of
game of thrones is returning to direct
this series and the great composer ramin
jawadi is doing the music once more and
you can actually hear these piano notes
might sound familiar to you they do
evoke the melody of jenny of old stones
[Music]
the dream
it was clearer than a memory
high in the halls of the kings who are
gone so that song comes from the song of
ice and fire books when the brotherhood
without banners takes arya to high heart
and the ghost of high heart requests
this song as payment for her prophetic
visions it's actually believed that it
was her prophecy of the prince who was
promised that led the targaryen line in
the future to force the mad king to
marry his sister the song's lyrics
lament jenny of old stones the woman who
prince duncan targaryen left the throne
for leaving the realm with the mad king
duncan and jenny and many other
targaryens would die in the tragic fire
at summer hall ah listen to me i'm
expanding on game of thrones lore that
none of the characters in the show would
know or care about let's move on when i
heard the sound of thundering bombs
splintering shields and ringing swords
and i placed my hair up on me i'm from
[Music]
and all the dragons roared as one
so young renera rides through the forest
followed by a white-cloaked kingsguard
most likely her protector sir kristen
cole and we get the shots of the tourney
at maidenpole that's to celebrate
viserys's ascension to replace his
grandfather and a duel between kristin
cole and the badass prince damon
targaryen and which i will just say
damon ends this getting pretty
humiliated so cole gives young rhaenyra
who's watching his laurel leading this
girl to crush on him hard actually
according to a fool named mushroom that
i really hope shows up in the show young
rhaenyra might have been coached by her
uncle damon to seducer kristen if that
sounds gross trust me it gets grosser
there's a hint to that creepy
relationship here as we see kristin
unsheathing his sword in front of
rhaenyra then we get this close-up of
viserys placing his hand on the armrest
of the iron throne and notice a stain of
blood is visible a cut on his finger
which is a major detail because in the
books the throne is made of these swords
that make the throne just really
difficult to sit in if you were to shift
the wrong way you'll cut yourself and
anyone who gets cut sitting on this
throne is believed to be cursed the
zerus curse will ultimately be the chaos
he leaves behind and as we will see
there is one warring ruler who will
later take this throne who will also cut
themselves then we see a dragon soaring
over king's landing this is cerax the
yellow scaled female dragon ridden by
rhaenyra soars over a younger version of
this city no it's younger because it is
soaring toward the dragon pit atop the
hill of rhaenys still fully intact and
looking magnificent this was built by
maegor the first as a great stone stable
for the dragons and during the events of
the series it will become a very
important location where traitors are
executed during the civil war and many
claim the dragons being kept here stunts
their growth and over the course of
history it does get destroyed which we
know from watching game of thrones when
those leaders have their summits in the
pits ruins a behind-the-scenes reel
earlier this week extended this shot to
show xerax flying toward the red keep
which you can see is still under a bit
of construction let's move on
they consider the matter urgent that of
your succession
who else would have a claim the
firstborn child
brenera no queen has ever sat the iron
throne
the king has an heir damon targaryen
here a royal carriage carts in allison
hightower to king's landing past a
statue of dragon presumably this is
baleria in the black dread the dragon of
the great aegon the conqueror i mean it
could be i mean i guess it could be one
of the other past kings dragons but i
mean he would have been the most famous
one at this point in history there's a
meeting of viserys's small council where
each of them have a billiard ball sized
uh orb sitting before them not sure what
these are i wonder if it could be how
they cast votes or maybe something they
have to eat to appease viserys joy in
viserys's meeting is his hand otto
hightower you can see his hand of the
king pin on his lapel this is alison
tytower's father behind the king is his
lord commander of the king's guard sir
kristen cole's predecessor sir harold
westerling on the rights to his left is
his master of laws lionel strong and his
grand maester and then his master of
coin and then at the other end joining
him is corliss velaryon this is a
renowned seafarer and lord of driftmark
an island kingdom near dragonstone and
for now the valerians are key allies to
the targaryens you notice their white
hair that comes from their intertwined
history with the targaryen bloodline
aegon the conqueror's son aenese married
alyssa velaryon so you know they're all
swapping this group is debating
viserys's successor otto hightower is
pushing this out of loyalty to his
daughter allison who gave viserys his
two younger male heirs aegon and aymond
corliss is pushing damon again this is
viserys his younger brother matt smith's
character whom coral is fought beside
and the war for the stepstones
ultimately viserys is going to appoint
his firstborn daughter rhaenyra anyway
and demand all the lords of the seven
kingdoms swear fealty to both him and to
her when alison chooses not to go along
with that that's how the civil war
begins we see damon riding into this
tourney just looking awesome in his
armor his dragon's wings sticking off
his helmet even his horse has matching
armor this while his young niece
rhaenyra looks on about to be smitten
with sir kristin cold we see rainier a
bit later on in her life strolling with
lenore velaryon that's cordless son you
can see their sigil of the sea horse on
his chest these two will end up getting
married but it does not last we see
damon with the city watch of king's
landing with their gold cloaks during
his brief time of master of laws damon
reformed the city watch and gave them
their signature gold cloaks leaving them
with immense loyalty for him that will
prove critical during this civil war
period on to the next clip i will not be
made to choose between my brother and my
daughter
[Music]
so princess rhaenyra and sir harold
westerling look out upon these warriors
representing various houses with sir
kristin cole out front you may recognize
the red archer on the green banner of
house tarly on the right beside it the
boar of house cake all you can also see
on the left side the silver ego on the
indigo field of house malister this is
likely sir lyman malister who fought in
this tourney and ended up defeating the
sir christian in the joust then this
fateful meet up on the walking bridge
lead in dragonstone dragons are flying
overhead and you can see syrax soaring
in front of the sun and on the level you
can see how the sunlight peeks through
the flaps of her wing just making it
look even more realistic by having it
interact with the environment on the
left that looks like demon's dragon
karaxis who we'll see more of later in
this trailer so let's move on
rene's succession will be challenged
knives will come out
[Music]
you are the king
your duty is to take a new wife
so corliss valerion talks with his wife
rainey she is a targaryen originally and
she's known as the queen who never was
she's gonna play a mentor role to
rhaenyra and a character i'm very
excited to spend a lot of time with then
a shot of damon strutting into the red
keep throne room carrying this hammer
and wearing a crown that he has
fashioned for himself this is the hammer
of craig's crab peter which damon
defeats in the war for the stepstones
the stepstones are the islands near the
broken arm in a southern narrow sea
damon and corliss fight in this war
against the triarchy that's the
principality of dorne in this time in
history on to the next clip i've decided
to name a new heir i'm your hair
is a foot
do you think the realm will ever accept
me as that queen a woman would not
inherit the iron throne because that is
the order of things
when i'm queen i will create a new order
so viserys holds the sword blackfyre
this was the targaryen ancestral sword
that was first carried by aegon the
conqueror but damon responding i'm your
heir is quite the statement because he
was never named the heir it was always
going to be either rhaenyra or allison's
son aegon ii but it just shows you the
balls on this guy and then back to this
tense meet up on the bridge so we see
damon targaryen leading the faction of
the blacks threatening otto hightower
representing the greens demon has come
to dragonstone to take this dragon egg
and with him is miseria a woman from
essos who becomes his mistress of
whispers and here she is carrying his
child and having to part ways from her
under reserves orders is gonna drive a
major wedge between damon and his older
brother we see younger rhinera with sir
kristen as she bristles against the
succession custom of male heirs as she
makes her plan to break the wheel does
it sound familiar yeah it's meant to
then we get this great shot of her
riding her dragon cerex we're gonna get
a lot of great aerial dragon sequences
on this series the budget has increased
my friends and this trailer isn't even
showing the best of it we won't even see
the best of it this season let's move on
your family has dragons
there are power men should never have
trifled with
[Music]
okay here we see the aftermath of the
war for the step stones damon is
fighting a soldier of the triarchy the
people from dorne and then we see a
steaming dragon egg and then damon in
the dragon pit with his dragon karaxis
fierce and red i love how when it
exhales it blows his hair back just
another example of the effects
interacting with the real environment to
sell this as real then another shot of
young aemond targaryen the moment he
approaches the largest dragon we will
see in the series vegar we only see its
feet entail but this thing is massive
this is a pretty important moment in the
book i'm gonna go into it here because
it does incite the rest of the events so
this comes after aymond interprets
something his father says to him as a
dare to mount a dragon so the boy sneaks
off to vegar and ends up joyriding this
thing around but it gets caught by a
young joffrey velaryon so 10 year old
eamon pushes three-year-old joffrey into
dragon [ __ ] i mean eamond is a bit of a
prick but this ends up in a nasty fight
between eamond and joffrey's older
brothers lucaris and jacarys eamon calls
these kids the strongs implying that
they are bastards and he knows what he's
saying because this is deeply insulting
to the entire family this fight ends
with luke cutting out eamon's eye the
parents get involved with this and the
feud goes on to curse both families
we'll talk about this more later but
let's move on if renera comes into power
she could cut off any challenge to her
succession
i am to inherit the iron throne
she will block my way
[Music]
our hearts remain as one
our hearts are never one
a shot of allison hightower and rhaenys
before the throne allison wears a
seven-pointed star necklace this is for
the faith of the seven though at this
point in history the faith hasn't yet
been established as the sanctioned
religion of the realm like the sept has
not been built yet there's another shot
of rainiero's dragon cerax and then a
shot of rainer approaching the crown
this would be after viserys's death the
kingsguard who was supposed to be loyal
to aegon ii end up stealing the crown
and bringing it to rhaenyra supporting
her claim this is a period when allison
is rushing to claim the throne using her
father otto the hand as the lord
protector both sides are being pretty
shady about this at least when it comes
to the claim to the throne it's hard not
to support rhaenyra in it even if a lot
of her actions are kind of messed up
then we get a shot of the older aymond
one eye training in combat now with sir
kristen cole so sir kristin goes from
being rainier's protector in the king's
guard to walking in on her with her
uncle damon in a brawl so he leaves
disgusted and now we see him going hard
training a major rival to damon and
raniere's claim eamonn goes on to be a
vicious player in the civil war the kid
is known for keeping a sapphire in his
eye socket and later just kind of covers
it with a patch and then we get this
famous moment from the fire and blood
book where allison and renera are seated
beside each other at a dinner alison is
wearing green rainier dressed in black
and crimson which is how the greens vs
the blacks tradition begins onto the
next clip imagine yourself
on the iron throne
[Music]
where is duty
where he sacrificed
here we briefly see a baratheon knight
whose horse nays you can see the
baratheon stag on the shield i assume
this is from the tourney but just keep
in mind the baratheons play a very
important role later on in this conflict
there is a bit of a skirmish above
storm's end and shipbreaker bay that i
don't want to get into yet because i
think this is going to end up being like
the amazing season 2 finale then there's
this stunning shot from the final blows
of the war for the stepstones showing
damon finishing off kraker with his own
hammer notice the crabs on the beach
krager got his name of crab theater
because he would stake men on the beach
and wait for the tide to go out so the
crabs would come in and start gnawing on
them we also see damon and caraxes just
torching these soldiers along the cliff
then there's this very important moment
in which allison snatches the dagger to
charge toward rhaenyra to demand justice
for young aemon's eye being cut out by
lukaris valerian yes this is the same
valyrian steel dragger that would go on
to play a huge role in the song of ice
and fire the same cat spot dagger used
to try to kill bran which littlefinger
used to frame tyrion but really that hit
was ordered by joffrey and a blade
reclaimed by the starks in game of
thrones season 7 and used in season 8 to
slay the night king one weapon behind
all of this family drama and there's a
very quick shot of karaxis and you can
see that he is wearing a saddle marked
with this targaryen sigil i love how
these things used to actually have
saddles on them let's move on to the
final section
i love that tension and the acidity with
which rhaenyra says now they see you as
you are insane it's allison that way
just to get under her skin renier is
savory in this moment because it finally
forced alison to lose herself publicly
in front of everyone and we end with a
shot of a dragon at first i thought this
might be veigar but it's actually cerax
fight the dragon rainer stood in front
of in the promo image having golden eyes
the funko for crx has green eyes like
this one does i really think they're
gonna save the visuals for the massive
vegard for the show's release this
series honestly looks pretty good and
since we already know how it ends it
just really allows these producers to
take their time with it and savor these
vicious moments between the characters
and the behind the scenes reel makes it
look like they are sparing no expense on
the sets in the vfx i can't wait to dive
into this follow me on instagram and
twitter at ea boss follow the rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you